well they reset the continuity in the
comic book so I suppose this was
inevitable
Justice League war as an animation
junkie I love DC animated movies they're
not all perfect but they're all worth
seeing and I probably will do individual
reviews on all of them if I can find the
time to get around to it but let's start
with the one that they used to reset and
bring things pretty much in line with
the new 52 that launched over at DC now
this in turn is intended to be the start
of a new continuing continuity which we
haven't really had since the end of the
Justice League TV show pretty much
everything that's come out as an
individual movie even though Bruce Timm
has been involved in a number of them is
not part of that previous continuity nor
has it been a consistent part of a new
continuity
they've all been individual films with
some basic consistencies and the
characters but they're not maintaining
the same voice cast all the time and
they're not maintaining a continuity so
this is supposed to be the start of a
new solid continuity where we keep the
same actors in the same characterization
and we get to see them across multiple
things which on premise has me really
excited cuz I did that kind of
continuity and it was one of the things
I really loved about the Batman animated
series and the Justice League and Batman
Beyond and I loved how tightly it all
tied together so I'm excited about that
notion that said this being the start of
it it's a bit of a mixed bag there's
some things that work there's some
things that don't that's not completely
atypical not all these movies are
brilliant but the things that don't work
I really don't like the fact that
they're probably gonna be recurring
problems now in this newly established
dcau but why don't we start with what
does work the action and this is
definitely an action movie no question
about that
it's all really well done really well
handled really well paced and is rather
impressive that the action doesn't get
boring considering that most of the time
the various characters are fighting
completely identical parademons bet
you've gotten really old and really
boring it doesn't it stays fun and some
of the voices are really good too I
seriously I could listen to Batman and
Green Lantern bicker at each other for
two hours and I will be very happy
Shazam turned out to be a surprise
highlight for me really dug him and most
of the other characters are serviceable
but there's real
two major issues that I've got with this
thing and they happen to be linked to
specific characters the first is
darkside darkside is the big baddie and
there's always been two aspects to
darkside that make him an interesting
villain one he is insanely powerful he
can obliterate almost anybody and this
does portray that very well the second
though is he's got a really good
intellect he can jump in there and take
you apart with his Omega beam he would
prefer not to he's Mach abelian by
nature he likes to sit back and pull the
strings that is completely lost in all
of this he just happens to be the boss
fight at the end of them fighting all
these identical parademons and he's
given so little personality that
honestly they could have swapped him out
for any number of equally power bad guys
he could have been dooms that he could
have been solomon grundy it wouldn't
have made much of a difference all they
needed was a really big strong guy who
could take a beating for the last chunk
of the action and they happen to pick
Darkseid which i think is a real waste
of the character that one more of an
issue with this specific film my other
issue though is one that I'm really
afraid is going to reverberate across
this rebooted continuity and that is
Wonder Woman now I've not been keeping
up particularly close with the comic
books anymore like I said I know they
rebooted with the new 52 and all that so
I know what's going on but I'm not
actually reading the comics I don't have
time and I don't have a local comic book
store so it's quite possible that Wonder
Woman as presented in this film is an
accurate representation of how she
exists in the new 52 and if that's the
case well then I suppose I should be
just as pissed at DC the comic books as
I should be with the makers of this
movie because she is horrible you need
to understand I love Wonder Woman and
part of the reason why this stinks so
much she's been done really well in
animation up to this point whether it
was in the Justice League TV show or the
solo Wonder Woman movie which was really
excellent and she just has this sort of
strength of Stoicism but they were
always able to give her layers and make
you human and now she's a frigging
punchline they overplay this
fish-out-of-water thing but these really
stale obvious not funny jokes and
there's over earnest line reading from
the act just playing or just make
worse and then they have to cheapen her
further by giving her an immediate and
obvious attraction to Superman which
just in my mind undercuts the character
completely one of the best things that
the Justice League TV show did was to
not do the obvious pairing of Wonder
Woman and Superman actually she never
clearly got romantically paired off at
all they implied something was going on
with Batman but they didn't even show
that because she is not defined by her
romantic interests or entanglement she
never has been so in her first
appearance in this new continuity to
show her kind of going ooh does Superman
it you have missed the point so like is
that really mixed bag the art style is
cool the action is top-notch although
they've got that same sort of thing that
the Man of Steel of live-action movie
had which is a complete disregard for
civilian collateral damage I think it's
one thing to destroy villains in a fight
but the fact that none of these heroes
are going ooh should we check to see if
there were people in that building or
nobody says we got to get this fight
away from a populated area and they just
destroy everything yeah so again it's
not bad but the problems I have a better
kind of amplified by the fact this is
kick starting a new community and I just
worry that these problems there won't be
fixed or I'm just gonna be stuck with
them forever but I'll have to wait and
see because I'm definitely gonna come
back for more I have loved these films
and I'm gonna stick with them there have
been some rough patches before
Superman unbound but they've come back
strong since then so I will be back and
hopefully things will pick up a bit do
you follow the DC animated movies what's
your favorite one of the ones that have
been released so far there are a lot of
good ones out there I'm honestly I think
I gotta go with one room and that's
largely out of a love of the character
though there are some other really
excellent ones out there return of the
Joker is a second for me which I know
might be achieved because that's part of
the old kind of whatever it's awesome
anyway what's your favorite drops on me
down in the comments and let's talk
about it as for me I'll be back as soon
as I get my next fix